Il y a des normes qui sont appliquées dans ce pays
quand on est agriculteur,
qui forcément vous oblige à produire
quelque chose à 1 prix qui est déjà entre guillemets
hors marché.
Non seulement vous gagnez rien
et en plus vous savez pas le vendre parce que c'est
trop cher. Il y a 1 vrai problème, ça veut dire qu'il
y a 1 volaille sur 2 qui est importée.
Ah oui, mais il y a 1 vrai de prix.
Y a 1 problème évidemment de prix directement lié à ça.
on peut faire toutes les lois également qu'on veut.
Y a 1 moment,
il faut traiter quand-même le problème à la base,
nous on a 1 coup de
production qui est anormalement élevé par rapport
déjà aux autres pays européens,
et c'est ça qui est pas normal.
Nous, on doit produire avec certaines règles plus dures,
des fois que nos voisins, hein.
Donc à partir de là, réglons déjà ce problème de fond.
Donc en clair,
je pense que c'est directement lié, il faut dénormer,
il faut enlever
effectivement des normes et des contraintes. Et alors
vous vous.